[MUSIC]
Welcome, my name is Will.
I am one of the admissions officers
here at the Stanford Graduate School of
Business.
I'm joined by my colleagues which
we'll do a brief introduction shortly.
But I want to make sure that we're able
to orient ourselves to what's going to
be happening today.
This is our very first
application week and we are so
excited about having
the opportunity to really
dive into some of the topics that
we get a lot of questions about.
In our information sessions,
we typically do a high level overview.
And there's so much room for
us to get into those weeds,
help answer some of the questions you
have, and really unveil kind of some of
that mystery that often surrounds
the admissions process.
Today, we're going to be focusing on
testing transcripts and academic history
kind of broadly, as those also sit under
the umbrella of intellectual lighthouse.
What does that all mean?
I'll cover that in this introduction
of what is the holistic review process?
From there we'll do our
panelists introductions and
these are two panels that I'm so
excited to spend time with today.
We'll have a little bit of a moderated
question and answer session,
conversational in nature, and
then we'll turn to your questions.
So today, our goal is to help you better
understand testing, transcripts, and
academics within the kind of understanding
of the admissions process here at the GSB.
Our other goal and it's maybe
the goal I'm even more excited about,
[LAUGH] is being able to share tips,
best practices,
and things to consider to help you
put your best foot forward when it
comes to applying to business school and
hopefully here at the GSB.
All right, so the holistic review process.
What is it?
It is something that may be a little
bit of a foreign concept to some folks,
in fact, admissions is often
a foreign concept to people.
But the holistic review process is kind
of the philosophy that we use as we're
reviewing applications.
Here's a definition that
I really appreciate.
Holistic as a philosophy is characterized
by comprehension of the parts of
something as intimately interconnected and
explicable only by reference to the whole.
For us, that means we are making
our admissions decisions on
the entirety of the pieces
that you send to us.
As we're thinking about
that evaluation process,
couple questions right off
the bat that we often get.
So we do not use a formula,
an equation, or
algorithm in any of our
admissions decisions.
Kind of in-line with, hey,
are there any kinds of structures or
funneling systems that happen?
There are no benchmarks, no cutoffs, and
no quotas of any kind in our
evaluation process either.
We often get the question, I hear or
is it true that you only take x amount
of people from my industry or
x amount of people from my country?
And that is not true.
We are evaluating you as an individual
within the greater context of where you're
coming from, because you'll see two
lines down from here, context matters.
And no one part of the application
matters necessarily more than any other.
So today we are going to step away
from the questions of here is my GPA,
here is my testing,
am I competitive or not?
And really kind of shift
the focus to think about, okay, so
what is helpful for me to know about so
that I can put my best foot forward?
That's where we start talking about
context and I have a feeling, well,
we'll talk a lot about this year and
different ways for you to let us know
about the context of either your academic,
intellectual, and/or other achievements.
So what are we looking for?
So I gave you kind of that philosophical
rundown when we're looking for
things in three buckets.
First, intellectual vitality.
This is the one where we're really
going to be talking about today,
testing transcripts,
academics as a marker,
some markers of potentially many
of that intellectual vitality.
Demonstrated leadership potential and
personal qualities and contributions.
Rather than go through all three right
now, I highly encourage that you check out
our MBA admissions evaluation
criteria web page.
There's a lot of really great information
there and freely accessible language.
Rhetorical questions on intellectual
vitality that can help you uncover what
are some of the ways this
might come to life for you.
And in the case of demonstrated
leadership potential,
we actually outlined some of the different
types of leadership competencies that
you might be exhibiting in your everyday.
Where do we find this?
Throughout your whole application.
I like to use this visual as
a representation that each part
of the application helps us
understand one piece of who you are.
It is almost like that analogy
of the three wise men or
the wise people who were touching
different parts of the elephant.
And each one, because they couldn't
see someone was touching a foot,
someone was touching the trunk,
someone was touching the tail,
they all had different
interpretations of it.
But once they were able to
take their blindfold off and
see the entirety of what it was,
there was so much more, and
a very different outcome than what
they might have thought before.
That's similar to the application process.
We are taking a look at everything you
submit to get a better sense of who you
are, how you might show up in our
classrooms, and in our community.
So with that preface,
I'm going to stop share so
we'll be able to focus our attention
on our conversation today.
And if we could start with Christine,
we'll have you start and
if you can introduce yourself.
And why is something meaningful for
you about our line of work,
about the profession of admissions?
>> Sure, thanks Will.
Hi, everyone.
My name is Christine and
I'm one of the admissions officers here
at Stanford Graduate School of Business.
And I've been working in
the admissions for many years now.
And I think one of the things that's so
rewarding about the work that we do is
that we are hopefully like we are today
spending some time educating and
raising awareness about the opportunities
in higher education for everyone.
So no matter what background you're coming
from, what academic experiences, or
professional experiences you've had,
helping to highlight what a graduate
degree and a particularly an MBA
degree can do for anyone.
Because there are so many options once
you're armed with this degree for
what you can do.
So I love getting to spend time
one on one with applicants and
admitted students and talking about
what they want to do next and
how the MBA from Stanford
might help them get there.
>> And Allison, quick introduction and
what's something about this
work that's meaningful for you?
>> Hi, everybody.
I'm Allison,
happy to be with you this morning.
In the context of learning, I think
what I love is not only when I'm reading
each of your application, I feel like
I'm opening a book on someone's life.
But I also feel like I'm getting a window
to the world because through all of your
essays and experiences from different
industries, and career stages,
and life experiences,
and all over the world.
I just feel like I learned so much about
the world through your personal journeys.
>> And for those of you,
one more time, my name is Will.
And one of the things that fuels me
is being able to be a part of your
educational journeys.
Whether you end up applying and
coming to Stanford,
applying elsewhere, or
deciding to go on another life path.
These are things,
how can I help you realize and
see what options are out there and
choose what's best for you?
I think that's something that
keeps me going every day.
So let's turn to the topic at hand,
we are going to be talking about
testing transcripts, academics,
and I would like to actually
start with this idea of stats.
There's a lot of tension and
anxiety out there about, hey,
the school's average GPA is this,
the school's testing average is that,
can we unpack a little bit together?
What do those stats mean?
How to interpret it?
And should someone count themselves out of
applying if they don't meet those numbers?
So any initial thoughts, clearly,
I have a lot of feelings about this.
[LAUGH]
>> Let me start,
I would just say our
potential applicants tend
to obsess too much about the numbers.
GMAT scores, theory scores, your GPA, and
please know that we don't look
at any of you as a number.
And not only are we forming
a class of students, but
we're also forming a community.
So you are much, much more than whatever
your GPA is or whatever your GRE score is.
And as Will refer to earlier,
there's no minimum scores,
there's no target scores
that we're looking for.
>> And then, go ahead, Christine.
>> I was just going to build on Allison's
mention, I know so often as you're
starting your research, and
you're learning about different schools,
one of the first places you visit will be
that class profile for different programs.
And I would just encourage you all not to
anchor too much on what the averages or
the medians might be there because you
must remember that's kind of just that
middle ground.
There are going to be students at
both ends of that spectrum and
it's a pretty wide
spectrum at most schools.
So don't necessarily count yourself out
just because you may not be necessarily
close to one number.
Because Alison said, there are so
many different things to consider.
And as Will mention there, so
many places we go looking for
that intellectual vitality.
>> And I guess the other thing to remember
too is that class profile you're looking
at, that's just one particular year.
So they change from year to year because
our students change from year to year.
>> Yeah, that's true.
And so maybe the natural
extension of that question is, so
those numbers are a figment of who
ends up getting admitted as opposed
to targets that we're trying to reach.
That's like a very different philosophy.
So as we think about testing transcripts,
how do we use those in
the evaluation process?
Can you shed any light
on that piece of it?
>> Allison, I'll kick us off and maybe
you'll add in if I've forgotten anything.
So I think it's important to remember
that when we're taking a look at
your application, as Allison mentioned,
we're building this class,
we're shaping a community here on campus.
But that is all around the idea of
business school, as we all mentioned.
We are here focusing on your education and
we ultimately want to make sure
that students are joining us who will
be able to thrive in the classroom.
So one of the things that we are looking
at with your transcripts and
your test scores is your ability to handle
some of the quantitative coursework that
you'll be facing in an MBA program.
So that doesn't necessarily mean that
you have to come from a quantitative
background, in fact,
many of our students don't.
So it's just a matter where you may
have had some exposure to those concepts
in different places, whether it be
in the classroom, through tests, or
even in your workplace.
So again, it's not only limited to your
tests and transcripts at some point, but
we do go there as a first place to start
to get a sense of what quantitative
exposure you've had so far.
>> And I would just add to bring us
back to the evaluation criteria and
the first one we mention
was intellectual vitality.
There's all sorts of ways to show that and
I think a lot of us know people that
we've been in class with where maybe
they had really high grades, but
they didn't necessarily have
intellectual curiosity.
And I think the opposite is true,
we may see somebody with lower scores,
but maybe they did original research as
an undergraduate, which is pretty amazing.
Or maybe at work,
they wrote kind of a white paper that
took some research and was beyond.
So when we talk about
the holistic evaluation,
we're diving deeper than just
the scores and the numbers, and
we're looking for
examples of intellectual vitality
>> I'm actually going to jump into the Q&A
box because there's a question
here from Anjan from Serbia.
And I hope, I'm sorry, if I mispronounced
your name, but they would like to
know about the GMAT/GRE kind of within
that umbrella of intellectual vitality.
And I think this would be
a really great place to unpack
intellectual vitality itself.
I like to think of it as,
what's your relationship with knowledge
of just the way Allison was talking
about what are some of those things
that kind of spark your curiosity.
I kind of tried to slip in a little bit
kind of easy intro for all of you to start
thinking about what are the things
that excite you in our introductions.
But Allison and Christine, any thoughts
on kind of intellectual vitality overall?
And kind of what are those pieces
that you already explain a little bit
about markers that you
might succeed in the class?
But any other thoughts on IV,
Intellectual Vitality broadly?
>> I guess another example that comes
to mind in terms of intellectual
curiosity is you may have been
someone who really sought out,
really hard classes in university and
classes outside of your major,
and you didn't do
particularly well on them.
But again, there's the grade and
then there's this pattern of seeing
that you were often taking harder
classes or ranging far from your major.
And so again, I think for me,
a lot of it is curiosity and
the kind of energy to
follow that curiosity
even if sometimes it's difficult.
>> Yeah, and I would say sometimes it's
not only just about the difficulty level
of a class, but if you were a double
major, or you had a minor, or two minors.
That was a way that during
your undergraduate experience
you were expressing and
exploring your intellectual curiosity.
Sometimes that surface because
you were just curious and
you weren't sure what
the right path might be.
Others were really clear and
were very particular about which
classes they chose to participate in.
So those are all subtle things in
the transcript that we're looking for, but
I would also take take us out
of the transcript for a minute.
One of the other places that
intellectual curiosity will surface for
us is actually through your
extracurricular activities.
If you have hobbies or
different organizations that
you might be involved with outside of
work and outside of the classroom.
That can actually pop there too because
oftentimes you're drawn to different
activities because you have
a particular interest or passion in it.
So it does surface in many places.
>> And you can also say that for work,
too, like what are some insights you might
have had that have shaped the way
a project or outcome has turned out?
It's this broad concept of ideas, maybe?
And what are the ideas that excite you,
knowing that some ideas are going to
be explored in the classroom, and
some might actually be more exciting and
dynamic in that professional realm?
So really thinking broadly about that.
So I love that and we actually already
started to go into transcripts.
And as someone that I highly respect and
invites conversation like this,
let's go there.
[LAUGH] So
let's talk about the transcripts.
Allison, you started,
Talking about GPA and
looking beyond just that single number.
GPA is a single data point, but
actually doesn't tell me much
when I'm reading an application.
The transcript itself as a whole is so
much more interesting and has so
much more data and
information about you to it.
Can we talk a little bit about how
we look at kind of the coursework,
trends anything like that
within the transcript itself?
>> Yeah, well, we talked some about
taking classes outside your major.
I think we do look at
the rigor of your major and so
you may have been pre-med or
electrical engineering major.
So the GPA may be lower, but
I guess what I'm saying is
we look at the context.
We look at your performance within
the context, so maybe tough major.
So maybe you were the first person in
your family to ever go to college.
Maybe your family
immigrated to the States so
English isn't your first language.
So we really look at the broader
context in terms of things that may
have contributed or
affected your performance.
>> I'm actually going to expand that
context even further because I know
there's additional context
that we also consider.
And that is what was happening in
your life outside of the classroom.
So maybe you were on a varsity
sports team and we know the time
commitment that is required if
you're a member of a sports team.
Maybe you were working part time or
in some cases,
maybe full time while you were in school.
And that might have impacted the amount
of time you were able to devote to your
studies and your coursework.
Maybe you were working on campus
serving as a teaching assistant or
a research assistant.
So understanding the context
within which that you were
pursuing your education is also really
important for us to understand.
>> And I guess I want to mention too that,
why is any of this important
in terms of your grades.
I mean, as Christine mentioned, of course,
we want you not to just to survive here,
but thrive here.
But it's not like we want these grades
because we are focused
on your achievement.
A lot of the learning here at
Stanford is from each other.
So we care a lot about if you're
the kind of person who loves ideas,
is going to challenge each other and
the professor inside the classroom and
outside the classroom.
So a lot of that has to do not just
with want you to be a high achiever but
we want you to be an active contributor
not only to your own education but
to your classmates.
>> Yeah, I think on that front something
that I think of a lot about is if I
were In an applicant's shoes if I
was applying to business school,
I know my academic history and
I could have prepared better.
And so I think a lot about,
college was a different time in my life.
So I actually think a lot
about is that who I am?
Or are there things that we can do,
or that someone out there can do,
to show that they have demonstrated or
that they have those abilities and
can demonstrate it in a classroom or
learning environment.
I think this might be the first time
we've ever actually gone into tips,
best practices.
Things folks out there
can do to go out and
kind of take ownership of their
journey for lack of better words.
And before we go into the space, I do want
to put out the disclaimer that we don't
necessarily recommend that you
do one thing versus another.
But really take that step back to see,
okay, what is realistic for for
me given what whatever's around me
resources, time, accessibility.
So again, this is not going to be
a set of hard and fast rules, but
rather things that we might have seen and
maybe ways of thinking about it.
That can help you even beyond
just the application process.
We've had a lot of applications.
What are some of the things that either
we've seen or kind of could think about
for folks who want to beef up that
kind of academic preparedness?
>> So in terms of that, well,
where I think you might be going here
is if you're say coming from
social sciences background,
you're an English major, a history major.
Maybe you didn't really need to take
too many math or science classes and so
you know we are going to be looking for
your quantitative exposure.
You're not required to take pre-coursework
before you join the MBA, but
some people do find it helpful.
So you may want to take advantage of
all of those amazing online resources,
local community colleges.
There are a lot of ways to gain
exposure to some of those concepts.
But it is entirely up to you, again, not
a requirement for our application process.
You should check for
other schools that might have them.
But for us, it's really about
just expanding your mind,
getting comfortable with
some of these concepts.
And some of those do come with fees, but
many of those can actually be accessed for
free online now.
So there is a way to gain that exposure.
And we have seen some people
do it before they apply.
Others don't do it before they apply, but
they make the choice to actually gain some
of that experience before
they start the program.
So in the summer leading up to school,
sometimes they'll take advantage of some
of those online resources or
taking a class before they start the MBA.
>> Yeah, so Christine,
what happens if I'm signed up for
a class that is after the decision or
after the application deadline?
How should I convey that?
Should I convey it?
Is that important?
>> Absolutely,
it's certainly worth mentioning.
So when in doubt,
whenever you feel like there might be some
piece of your intellectual or academic
journey or story that can't be clearly
explained or expressed in the application.
That is where the additional information
section will come in in your application,
which is not meant to be just a whole
separate essay, but rather a place as
a catch all really, for anything that
you just need to inform us about.
So it could be a single bullet point or
sentence that says I've registered to take
this class and I'll be starting it and it
could be after the application deadline.
This is also a place where if you had any
struggles or challenges during undergrad,
either an overall GPA or
maybe just a particular class.
If you feel like there's additional
context that you need to explain to us,
for where those grades
might have come from,
you can use that additional
information section there.
We've definitely seen that utilized for
anyone who was explaining whether it
was an illness or an injury that may
have prevented them from taking a test.
And that affected their final grade in
a class, that you can let us know there.
There is a space so you don't leave us
to our own devices to make up stories.
You can tell us exactly what happened.
>> And I would encourage folks to think
about if you're going to do any of
this academic preparation.
Maybe it's just been a long time
since you've had to do either
intensive reading or writing.
To think about preparing for the MBA
itself, you know, work towards a goal
that you'll be able to hit the ground
running once you're at school.
because that is going to help you long
term as opposed to just taking a class for
the sake of applying.
And I hope that mentality will set
you up better for long term success.
In terms of what classes to think about,
you actually know your kind
of academic history the best.
And this is where I would encourage you
to take that kind of step back again,
and take control of the narrative.
If you know there's an area that you
might have struggled with in the past,
that could be an area to think about
doing a little bit of additional work on.
We talk a lot about
quantitative skills and
the quantitative elements of
the business school experience.
But I would also encourage folks to
Practice reading practice writing,
communication and verbal skills are also
going to be a huge part of MBA experience.
I know Allison was just talking
about how do you challenge ideas and
have constructive dialogue where there
are differences of opinion because
that's where learning happens.
I think Dean Levin talks about
learning happens when you embrace
the difference and so
how are we able to communicate that?
So we covered a little bit about
transcripts so now can we let's
just shift over to testing like
there's a lot of questions and
even in our q&a box about,
okay, the test score,
you get one score, but
there's also sub components.
Can we talk a little bit about that and
how that kind of factors in among
the other parts of the application.
>> I guess I'd start by just reminding
people that just like everything in
the application,
we keep telling you that we look at it in
context same thing with the test scores.
So for example, the verbal score we're not
going to expect as high a verbal score,
for a non-native speaker as
a native English speaker,
of course with a quantitative score.
If you were that History or
English major, you may not, and
you probably won't have as high
a quant score as that physics or
engineering majors so,
we look at each piece in context and,
as will said, there's no minimum score.
But I should say with
the English proficiency exams,
there are hard minimums, for obvious
reasons you need to be fluent in English
before you get here but
with the GMAT, GRE, no minimum.
>> And remind me, Alison, those are
actually set by the university as a whole,
correct?
>> For the English proficiency.
Right?
Yeah.
>> But well,
since we're talking about tests,
I'd love to remind everyone now that
whether we're speaking about the GMAT,
GRE or the English language proficiency
exams, you all have options.
So we accept both the GMAT and
the GRE and there are no preferences
between those two exams.
So usually what I personally recommend and
speaking for myself, but before you sign
to take another test you can take free
practice questions online with both tests,
so you can get a sense or a feel for
what each test is like and
if you find that you might be
scoring better versus the other,
maybe that's the test to consider and
that might be the one you want to take.
If you think that'll give you the
opportunity to put your best foot forward
there on a testing standpoint, and
when it comes to the English language
proficiency is we accept three
different tests that are TOEFL the IELTS
and the Pearson test of English.
So yes, there are minimums for each of
those that are set by Stanford University
but again, there are different tests and
ways of asking you those questions so,
you can be selective in terms of
which tests you're choosing to take.
>> And can we have a very wide
range of scores in the class,
you will see,
high average scores at Stanford and
it's not because we're in aiming for
particular score that those
averages tend to reflect our applicant
pool in terms of who applies.
But many times we've had people in
the class, into the five hundreds and
I can remember one particular case
where we actually had someone in
the class who got 450 GMAT now not
saying you should aim for 450 GMAT,
but the point was the person had quite
a low score and they did perfectly fine.
>> And so I think that also goes into our
conversation about the sub scores one,
of them, again, is not necessarily more or
less important than the other and
then we're looking across both
your academic history as well
as what are some of the things
you're doing in your workplace.
I think that is somewhere that folks don't
often think about when we're thinking
about that intellectual vitality and
what are some of the skill sets and
knowledge sets that are going to help set
you up for success in business school?
And that's actually one of the questions
here from user who's asking
about those subsections and
I can say that I have seen instances where
someone did not have that many math
courses in their academic background.
Testing was fine and in their workplace,
they were doing a lot of
financial analysis modeling so,
it demonstrated ok, yes this individual
does have that wherewithal to be
able to thrive in different class
settings and in different environments.
At Business School, so thinking about
it even holistically and very broadly
beyond just here's that one section and
what does that one thing tell us?
Again, it's like no one
pieces like entry gate, but
really we're looking at the entirety
of your application to find things.
>> That's something to that
your recommender might mention,
they might talk about Analytical
projects you've done or
projects that required a lot
of reading and writing and
give us another data point about
your quantitative and verbal skills.
>> Okay?
And because I mentioned the word holistic,
maybe a million times during this
conversation, there's actually
a question here from Alex,
about how much time does does an admission
officers spend to holistically
evaluate a candidate any thoughts?
I have a thought but I'm really curious
to hear what your responses are.
>> Well you notice that Christina and
I both have rather thick laughs.
>> [LAUGH].
>> And that's no accident over so
many years of reading.
>> [LAUGH].
>> Absolutely,
and I would say I you probably saw
me chuckle there when you were
asking the question because I think we all
read at our own different personal pieces.
I know how much time it takes me to read
my change depending on what time of day it
is so, the most important thing for
us is that we are reviewing every
piece of that application and
some people might read a little faster,
some might read a little slower.
Some people might read and then take
longer to really think about, making any
decisions and so we're all kind of working
at our own paces, but we're all on that
same mission to make sure we're treating
every applicant with full respect and
reading every portion of that application
before reaching any conclusions.
So the actual number would probably vary
pretty widely depending on the day or
the time of year even
>> Yeah, and I will, go ahead Allison.
>> I was just going to say for us, it's
sort of like peeling back the onion so,
for example, if we do see a low GPA, we're
going to be asking ourselves, why is that?
Is there any circumstances there?
Is there any countervailing
evidence like GMAT score
GRE score to mitigate the GPA or
performance at work?
So.
>> And my half joking half serious answer
is as long as it takes some applications
are pretty clear cut like,
here's someone evidence is here,
it's clear there's
shining recommendations.
Okay?
Here's someone we might want to
consider it those ones go quickly, they're
also somewhat, maybe the preparation
is here we're not seeing some of that
demonstrated leadership potential so.,
those might go quickly as well.
And then the ones that take the longest
are often the ones that have the pieces
contextual information or dots that we
need to do a little bit more connecting,
so that like, as Christine was saying,
like we are giving a fair and like how
can we best honor the entirety of this
application to give a fair assessment?
And so it really does.
Differ by individual kind of environmental
conditions and also by application.
So a couple of different factors there.
But at the end, I actually really value
and appreciate our reading system.
And it's actually one of the things that
keeps me in this job is that we're able to
do things holistically.
>> Okay.
>> So let's go into,
we're actually going to start
leaning more into the Q and A box.
I think there's some really
great content here, Christine,
there was a question that I saw
earlier about deferred candidates.
Like they still have a chunk of their
senior year usually left to go.
So, for our different candidate and for
admission, that is when you're applying in
the final year of your bachelors or a grad
program if you gone all the way through.
Can you talk a little bit of
how we view those transcripts,
knowing that there's going to be a little
bit a chunk of them that's not going to be
full, by the time they apply?
>> Absolutely, well and again, we're
going to use that word context again.
It's about us understanding what you've
done with the time you've had so far.
So, for
students that have been working for
five years will have the full kind of past
tense view of how you did an undergrad.
With our deferred students who might
be applying during their senior year,
we'll see how you've done in your first
three, or three and a half years.
So we'll get a sense of how you performed
in the classroom most recently,
you'll be able to take the tests while
you're still in that kind of study mode,
while you're still a student.
And so, that will give us just
kind of a moment in time,
understanding of how you
performed in the classroom.
So our expectation that is if
that you're performing well now,
hopefully you are preparing and
will be performing well.
Two to four years from now and you might
be joining us in the MBA classroom,
but it is just a piece and
it is a moment in time.
So, like with all of our applications,
these are just some of the data that we're
considering when reviewing
your entire application.
>> And we will ask for that final
transcript for that last semester,
[LAUGH] in the summer before you come so,
keep your grades up.
[LAUGH]
>> Here's a tactical practical question.
So going into some of the logistics of
it and this question is from Konica.
Are we open to considering the highest
section scores from different sittings?
Or do we consider the overall
like a single sitting or
the overall highest G-Maggiore?
>> Good question, but officially we
will need you to report a single score.
So from a single sitting, so you may
have taken the test say two times and
you had a higher verbal on one and
a higher on other.
You can't mix them together and
you'll have to pick one of
those overall scores to report
to us in your application, and
you'll be self reporting
in the application.
I think I saw another question in
that Q and A box that, what if I take
the test and the official scores may
not be in, in time for the deadline?
That's okay, because you're self
reporting on the application.
It's okay if the official scores post
right after were a little after that
application deadline.
But ultimately,
you can only there's only space in the
application to report one full test score.
>> Here's a question from Catarina and
I have to admit I love this question.
I love when we're able to unpack,
and demystify, and
really add information and
me too rumors that are out there.
And so here's one who they've heard from
previous students that the bar is much
higher for international students,
are the expectations higher because
we come from outside the US?
Let's discuss this one.
Let's dig into this one.
>> Yeah,
we love busting these myths in it,
it makes our blood pressure go up,
we hit some of these nerves.
I would say that the only difference
is that English proficiency exam that
you do need to be fluent in
English before you get here.
And so yes, the,
I wouldn't say the bar is higher, but
there is a far minimum on each of those
three English proficiency tests and
you do need to meet that minimum.
And I don't know Christine,
that's the only difference I can think of.
>> I would agree because, otherwise,
when we're looking at the G-Maggiore,
or the transcripts, we're looking at
everything exactly as we as we do for
every application that we read.
So, looking for those same instances or
examples of intellectual vitality and
curiosity.
And the context in which we consider how
people ended up with the grades that they
did, through all of the things that
Allison had mentioned earlier,
the majors and other things that
might have been happening outside,
all of that we look at every application
in with the same kind of perspective.
So it really is just those
minimums that again,
are set by Stanford, and
the reason those minimums are there,
is because the the coursework here
is taught entirely in English.
Again, we do want to make sure that people
will not only be just kind of getting by
in the classroom but being active
participants in the experience.
>> Yeah, and I would also say that we
read a lot of international applications.
So we also have a very
good sense of what some of
the different academic
kind of systems are.
And also,
not everybody is graded on the same scale.
And so sometimes when people are trying
to translate or do correlations,
I think there's a lot that gets
lost in translation there.
I know there was another
question of crier in the Q and
A box that had to do like
what GPA do we report?
We do, there it is.
Do we use it for
each unique year or do we use
the cumulative at the end of each year?
So, not all schools will do
that report what you have, and
I would say reported in the grading system
and grading scale that you attended.
We want to see how you did in
the context of your education.
And even within the American system,
I could see there's like,
I've seen 4.0 scales.
I've seen 5.0 scales.
I've seen there are schools that
don't give us a grade, a letter or
a number but there's a full write up for
every course they've taken.
Those are fun to work through.
So we are very [LAUGH] comfortable
with a wide range of these systems.
But, as both Alison and
Christine were saying like there is no
different standard that we hold for
international candidates, I think that
context piece does play come into play.
Sometimes the language element because
maybe your first, second, and or
maybe third or beyond languages were not
English, and that might pull down and
overall geomat score make
things look different.
So, I would set that myth to rest.
We are looking for the same criteria, and
the same types of talent, ability and
perspective or a breadth of talent,
skills and perspectives diversity within
diversity from [LAUGH] all over Africans,
no matter where they come from.
Alright, question, continuing on
this theme of international and
academics and other contexts,
if our transcripts aren't in English,
do we need to have them translated?
Is it okay to translate them ourselves?
How should someone approach that?
>> Yes, when you send the copies of the
transcripts, often times we may see both,
so, we may see the official
in your original language and
then a translated version.
Because despite our best efforts,
we can't read all of the languages, but
it is sometimes helpful to see both.
But, some of you,
sometimes people will use different
services to do the translations.
So, there's some flexibility when you're
applying, because we're looking for
copies of your transcripts at this time.
But if admitted, we will need to
see the official transcripts and
we will need an official
translated copy at that time.
Thank you.
And so you just mentioned,
can apply with an unofficial transcript,
will request an official one later.
I know sometimes that has
been a topic of conversation,
we understand that sometimes requesting
transcripts cost additional money,
if you're applying to many business
schools, that might increase the cost.
So we're really trying to be as sensitive
as possible throughout this process.
Also knowing that sometimes it's just
really difficult to get official
transcripts, especially if maybe you
haven't attended school for a long time.
There can be a lot of different
hoops you have to jump through.
So we're trying our best to ease
that process wherever we can.
Okay, and here's another question and
I think it tailors nicely
with this question of,
maybe I'm still doing some preparation,
maybe there's things that I'm still doing.
When should someone apply, right?
What point should we be thinking about, I
need to have everything in my application,
or what are things that it's
okay to update later on?
When does that make sense?
How should I be thinking about kind
of the two possibilities out there?
>> And then of course, obviously
there's when you want to start school,
which is probably the first cut, but
then it's really when can you
present the strongest application.
And when you update things
later after the deadline,
they will become part of your file but we
can't promise that they'll be considered,
we may have already read your application.
So I would say, if you're waiting for
something really important,
like well, in fact, with the GMAT,
if you're going to retake it or
the GRE score, that does need
to be taken before the deadline.
So, I would say,
minor things could be updated, but
if it's something really important
to the strength of your application,
you'd want to do it before you apply.
>> Great, thank you.
And here, let's round into this
question again, kind of we've
approached it from different perspectives,
but I don't think we've actually named it.
So the question is,
from someone who does not necessarily
have the broadest quant background, and
maybe some of the obvious places, but
how can they communicate
quantitative abilities?
Do they always need to, or
in what spaces does it make sense?
>> Yep, I think Alison talked about this
a little bit earlier on in that again,
if it doesn't naturally or obviously
present in, say your test score or
in your academic background and
experience.
The workplace is oftentimes
where this will surface.
And in some cases, it might present
because you've told us in your resume,
maybe one of the line items under
one of your particular roles, or
your time at a particular company,
you're able to highlight a time when you
were working on something analytical.
But another place where
that surfaces a lot for
us is through the letters of
reference that we receive.
So your recommenders may be able to share
stories with us about how you were able to
display some of those quantitative or
analytical skills through
a different project that you might
have been working on in the company.
So there's a lot of different places,
and again,
even sometimes in your
extracurricular activities.
So, you may not be giving yourself enough
credit, you may be a part of a community
organization and
you had to organize a big drive.
And it turns out that you actually had to
keep things really organized and you were
actually using more of those kind of
muscles than you may have even realized.
So that may be an opportunity to share
some of those stories within your
application as well.
>> Yeah, maybe you're sharing some of
that in one of your written responses.
Maybe it's an optional response,
maybe just a bullet point or
two in your additional information if it
doesn't come up naturally somewhere else.
So we really provide
a lot of landscape for
you to use in a way that makes sense for
you.
So hopefully, if you're thinking about it,
and you're like, yes,
I do have these but it doesn't come
out obviously on my application,
let us know in one of these other spaces.
One more question that I
really want to ask our group.
I have come across, I've had a lot
of conversations about folks who
might not have had the most stellar
kind of initial undergraduate career and
then re-did or
had these other kind of journeys and
pathways that show that
they have these talents.
So, as we close out this session, kind of,
can we crystallize in just a few words,
how can you demonstrate this intellectual
vitality across a broad range?
Any thoughts, words of wisdom, words of
encouragement that you have for folks
out there, who might still be hesitating
because of a past that they have?
>> I guess mine are just a few reminders
that you do have that additional
information section if you do want to
explain some extenuating circumstances.
And also that we look
at the whole journey so
you may have started out with a weaker
GPA in the beginning of university and
then it got stronger, or
you may have done some
graduate work that had
showed stronger performance.
And that, again, we look at other
sources like your workplace,
your extracurriculars,
maybe you're in a robotics club and
my goodness,
you've done a lot of quantitative stuff.
>> I'll just kind of add on
top of what Alison mentioned,
remembering that your academic experience,
undergrad or graduate, if you've had any.
Again, it's a moment in time in
your very long life and journey.
And so if you didn't perform
as well in undergrad for
whatever reasons that might have been.
Knowing that you'll still have
an opportunity to demonstrate some of that
intellectual vitality through the testing
process, that could be an opportunity for
you to make sure you're spending
enough time studying and preparing.
So you have an opportunity to show what
we may not have been able to see earlier.
If you're one of those folks out there who
worry about testing that's not your strong
suit, I understand, I hear you.
And just know that if you are coming in
maybe with a lower GMAT or GRE in lower
grades, again that additional information
up there is a section where you can share
some of that contacts the rest of
the story to fill in those pieces for us.
And gain, just know that we are looking at
everything else that you've done in your
life beyond those two things, to try to
get full understanding of who you are and
what you have to contribute
to this community.
>> And I love how we've kind of zoomed
out through this process to really think
high level.
My words of encouragement are you are so
much more than two numbers
in an application.
There is the journey, as part of
that journey is that learning and
growth that you have
earned over your time.
If you're thinking about business school,
who are you now because
of those experiences?
What are some of the skill
sets that you now have so
that you can thrive when you are in
a moment of challenge again?
What are some of the things that do
spark your excitement to learn, grow and
in turn, share that knowledge with others?
I think, as we kind of step back and
really think about the wholeness
of who you are, the academic piece
is just one part of the story.
And I really encourage you,
if you aren't already,
check out our Sharing Your Story Workshop
Series, where we'll be able to impact
even more about how you can think about
these elements and moments in your life.
Such that you can really
put your best foot forward,
whether it's in a written format in
the application and interview, networking.
Or any other place where people
are trying to learn more about you and
you're building relationships, kind of
to move your career and life forward.
With that, if you haven't done so,
I also encourage you,
I'm doing a lot of
encouraging today apparently,
[LAUGH] I encourage you to start
at MyStanford.mba account.
With a couple questions we can
help you create a dashboard
that will consolidate
events of interest to you.
There's also an application tracker
that'll help you keep track
of where you are in the process to make
sure you're headed in the right way for
that round one, round two,
or round three deadline.
With that, thank you so
much for joining us today.
Hopefully, we were able to share some
good information, things that help you
better understand how we use Testing
Transcripts and your overall academic
history to better understand who you
are in this application process.
Hopefully, I'll see you around
throughout the rest of this week or
at other Stanford events.
Until then, take care and stay safe.
[MUSIC]